There's one more useful thing we can add to our polygon creator, changing the
radius of the polygon. By default, the distance of all the points from the
polygon center is 1. Now, modify the program to use a radius to make the polygon
generated larger or smaller. Here's your new interface. Notice that we've
changed the order of arguments here. In the previous problem, the location was
the second argument. Now it's the third. This is usually not a great idea,
especially in JavaScript, as this language does not really check if the number
of arguments passed in matches the number of arguments expected. We did it this
way because we felt the location change is a bit easier than the radius change
and wanted to save the trickier problem for later. When your work is complete,
this is what you should see on the screen.